hello good to see you brian yes nice to
see you as well
um so david and i have known each other
actually for quite a long time
and we first made contact because i came
across his book
of short stories called sun which is a
book that i would
very much recommend to anyone to read
it's some the subtitle is
40 tales from the afterlife and it's a
speculation
on what the various afterlifes available
to us might be like
they're very short stories but they're
very provocative and they're
very witty and um intelligent
in a in an interesting way and as indeed
is david i think
and it's interesting to me that i knew
him first as a writer
and only then discovered that he's
actually a neuroscientist
and i think the interesting thing about
his writing is that
his science writing is as sort of witty
and lateral as a lot of his fiction
writing
um there's something very approachable
and
undogmatic about it and i think don't
you call yourself a
possibilitarian or something like that
possibility
a possibility that's right yes yes so
um i think that's a word for somebody
who
admits to uncertainty about their
beliefs and says that
there are lots and lots of different
possibilities and i'm not going to
endorse any particular one
and i think that as a sort of thinking
style
makes for a very interesting kind of
writing
so a lot of them a lot of david's books
of course are based on
evidence and experiment and so on but
they're very interesting because there's
a lot of speculation in them as well
some is a book of pure speculation but
the
ability to speculate actually goes
through a lot of
david's work and this
latest book which is a really great read
called live wired is about
thinking about plasticity brain
plasticity
um at a much deeper level than
i've ever thought about it before and i
think at some
new levels that haven't been discussed
before really
so let's start with the title
instead of calling the book brain
plasticity david has chosen to call it
live wired
and perhaps we should just try to see
what he means by that
term that is that means more than brain
plasticity what's the difference between
brain plasticity and livewire yeah great
thanks for that question you know it's
um the term plasticity which is the term
we use in the field to
to represent the fact that you've got
these 86 billion neurons and they're
constantly reconfiguring and plugging
and unplugging and re
finding new places to plug and so on we
use the term plasticity for that but
that was
coined 100 years ago by william james
because he was impressed with
with plastic manufacturing and the idea
was you know you mold something into
shape and it holds that shape and that's
what makes
plastic really useful for us and so he
thought you know it's like the brain
learns something and changes its
configuration and then it holds on to
that that's why you can remember
something years later
so he used the term plasticity but i
think given the size of what we now
understand
the days of being impressed by plastic
manufacturing are over because what's
happening in this
giant forest is and in you know
every moment of your life this is
you know reconfiguring yes and um
yeah and so i i wanted a better term
than plasticity so so the idea is i also
wanted to distinguish
you know the way we think about
everything in silicon valley is hardware
and software
and what we're all carrying around is
three pounds of live wear it's a
completely different kind of material
than anything we know how to build but
it's a material that reconfigures itself
all the time yes so actually
the next question i was going to ask was
about that word livewear
is that a new word for you from you
that's a new word yeah yeah yeah
that's a very useful word because the as
you said the idea of plasticity
is that the brain remolds itself and
then stays fixed
which is actually not what happens um
the brain is
always remolding itself so you have
exactly you have this notion of us
as sort of permanently unfinished beings
where we never reach a terminal state
actually well except when we die
that's a good one
[Laughter]
you know i started the book with a
heidegger quotation which i love which
is that
um you know each man is born
as many men and dies as one
and the reason it's such a lovely
quotation is because right we we have so
much um
you know potential it's sort of like one
of these space-time diagrams where you
might go off on any trajectory depending
on your experiences in the world
and of course this is what is special
about human brains is that we
absorb what is around us and i'll just
mention just by way of
just introducing part of this
conversation is you know
when we look around the animal kingdom
there's something so special about us as
humans
um animals are born into the world and
they generally
are pre-programmed in a sense so if
you're an alligator or a horse or
whatever you're
you know you just do your thing the same
thing that you did a hundred thousand
years ago but
humans dropped into the world we have
these incredibly long infancies and what
we're doing is
absorbing everything that humans have
learned before us so that we springboard
off the top of that
so we're we're the super live-wired
species we're just very flexible in our
and that's why we've taken over every
corner of the planet and gotten off the
planet
so so what's interesting though is is um
which parts of the brain are plastic
and which parts shouldn't be plastic
obviously not all of our brain is
permanently in a state of um flux
because
that would be very difficult for us to
negotiate anything as simple as picking
up a can of drink
for example so so what's
how does that work what are the sort of
what are the rules that determine which
parts are plastic and which parts
are not which parts are live where and
which parts are a little bit more
stable yeah so essentially it all starts
as
livewear but what happens i propose a
hypothesis in the book which is that
the the incoming data the more stable it
is the more the system kind of
crunches into place and becomes less
flexible around it so as an example
your visual system you know there's just
a certain number of
colors and angles and orientations in
the world and you you learn that
pretty quickly so your visual system
kind of crunches down into place
more rapidly than some other areas like
your your
motor system that drives your body why
because
as you go through life you get fatter
thinner you get you know tall
went from the time you're a baby and you
know you climb on scooters and pogo
sticks and trampolines and so on so
your motor system is always having to
figure out new body plans
um whereas your visual system is sort of
fixed into place and so what you find is
plasticity is not something you have as
a child when it stops instead you've got
all these closing
doors is the right way to think about it
that close at different rates
so just as an example you know something
like accent
if you move to a new country when you're
a child before let's say the age of 13
you can develop
accentless speech in the new country but
after about 13
you're always going to retain a bit of
the accent because that's sort of a
closing door there
and um and also you know there are these
very tragic natural experiments
with um feral children sometimes you
find a child
these are really heartbreaking but you
find a child who's been so abused and
neglected
by their parents that they haven't had
the normal
interaction with you know language and
love and touch and so on and they
end up very cognitively damaged
as a result yeah for example you find
this with the romanian orphanages after
the fall of chuchesku
there were tens of thousands of children
in these orphanages and the
staff simply didn't feel that they had
the
the ability to deal with this many
children so they said look don't talk to
them don't touch them that way the kids
won't become clingy
and uh and all these children ended up
with real cognitive damage because
brains
show up in the world with the
expectation of
interaction yes yes so so
obviously we can we can damage
our brains by abusing them that way
but is there any way that we can
positively
modify our plasticity is is there any
way we can exercise it
make it better more effective yes
yeah i mean the main thing is seeking
novelty because what the brain is
constantly trying to do
is build an internal model of the world
and part of the reason that plasticity
diminishes with age
is because we develop a pretty good
model of how to operate in the world
this is why as an adult you can be
successful it's why an eight-year-old
can't be
ceo of a company but an adult sort of
gets the rules of the operation um
and so that's the good news about
learning the world but the bad news of
course is your brain is less
less flexible and so the key is
seeking novelty always putting your
brain in situations where
it's between frustrating and achievable
whatever you're trying to do
and um you know finding finding new
challenges and by the way i'll just
mention you know the pandemic this past
15 months has been so terrible for so
many people
um the very tiny silver lining to it
is that it knocked us all off of our
hamster wheels i mean back in 2019 we
all sort of felt like okay i've got this
i know how the world works and
we all had to rethink so many things
including you know at the beginning
where do i get toilet paper where do i
get food and so on
but just i've seen a more general thing
where people are thinking about okay
what do i want to do with my life and do
i want to go back to the work that i was
doing before and so on
um it's really good for the brain to
take your internal model and shake it up
and try new things out yeah yes of
course
i had the depressing experience recently
of talking to a ceo of a
clothes retailing company who said with
great excitement
it's wonderful everybody's spending as
much money as they can again
and i thought i thought oh dear that's
that's rather depressing
i i had hoped that it might be the end
of the consumer society but
i don't think it's going to be this too
much no we're
yeah we're bouncing back into the
roaring 20s i mean it's just obvious
when you go to airports or any kind of
thing now everybody has really missed
being a part of the world
and so they're going to do more of it
yeah yeah well perhaps
perhaps they'll find it's a little bit
disappointing after all and they won't
do so much of it
i don't know but there's something in
the book that really interested me which
was to do with
the speed of these uh changes within the
mind i
i had all i'd known about plasticity
before but i thought it was a kind of
slow process
something that would happen over weeks
months or even years
but that isn't the case at all is it
things happen very very very quickly
that's right and this is a very new
discovery in neuroscience so
um it turns out that plasticity happens
at all kinds of time scales
but one of the things that comes as a
surprise is that the brain is extremely
cross-wired so you have
neurons brain cells from your auditory
system
that are reaching over all the way into
visual system and touch and so
and and vice versa and every everybody
has sort of silent sentinels into other
areas just in case something changes so
it turns out
that if you take a it okay so if you
take somebody who's blind and you look
at them in the scanner
you find that they're what we would have
thought of as their visual cortex
is being activated by sound by touch
things like that
because all that stuff gets taken over
but the surprise is
that if you take somebody who's sighted
and you blindfold them tightly and you
stick them in the scanner
within an hour you're starting to see
changes where there's some activity in
response to sound and touch
in the visual cortex within an hour and
this came as a big surprise because
exactly as you said nobody thought it
changes that fast but these silent
sentinels from hearing from touch
are reaching over and saying oh wait
there's no more visual data coming in
so let's start moving so here's the
thing we when you look at a neuroscience
textbook
you say oh here's the visual system
here's audition here's touch from the
body and so on
and it seems like everything is happily
fixed into place but in fact the whole
system is so
fluid it doesn't want any land to lie
fallow
and as soon as activity stops coming in
things start shifting and moving the the
springs are wound tight on this
and and so this led me to a completely
new hypothesis
about about why we dream at night and so
my student and i just published this
this past year um
it has to do with the falling what i
realized is given the speed of takeover
that can happen
the visual system in particular is at a
big disadvantage
because the planet rotates into darkness
for half the time
and in the dark you can still you know
hear and touch and smell and so on but
you can't see anymore and of course i'm
talking about evolutionary time not
electricity bless times so
what i realized is the visual system
needs some way to defend itself
against takeover in the dark when the
planet rotates
and that is what dreaming is about so
every 90 minutes you've got this very
specialized circuitry
that just blasts activity into the
visual cortex that's all it does it's
all dreaming is about
just blasting activity in there to keep
it defended against takeover from its
neighbors and of course because it's
your visual cortex you experience it
visually
and then because the brain you know is a
great storyteller we impose
narrative upon it and um you know
because some synapses are hot from
whatever you've been experiencing during
the day it's usually connected with
the content is connected with what
you've experienced but
anyway dreaming is a defensive
activation just to keep the visual
cortex defended
yeah that's such a beautiful theory
that's so
i think it's so elegant that um by the
way actually let me let me just mention
we just published a paper where we
looked at 25 species of primates in
great detail
and looked at how plastic their brains
are because some species like humans are
super flexible and others like gray
lemur uh great mouse lemur is you know
much
less flexible and we correlated that
with how much rem
sleep they get in an evening and it
turns out that they correlate perfectly
the more flexible you are as the species
the more dream sleep you have
um so anyway are we are we at the top
are we
at the top of that league we are the the
dreamers of the university yeah
yeah so yes i i used to have a theory
about
dreaming based on um 24 track technology
because
i was once i was falling asleep one
night and i
noticed i was thinking about a girl with
a shoe for a nose
and i realized i'd been thinking about
some new shoes i was planning to get
and this woman and my my dream state had
superimposed the two
and i thought oh i see what's happening
here it's just that we've got all these
separate tracks of thought in our mind
you know like
i'm sitting on this chair and feeling
how hard it is and it's quite warm here
i'm feeling that as well i'm worrying
about
a film i've got to make some music for
tomorrow all these different things
normally in in daytime we managed to
keep the narrator
straight he knows that this is the
important bit and these other bits are
superficial right now
but at night the that part of the brain
seems to switch off and
my theory of dreams was that we just
wander randomly through
all of these different channels of
thinking that we have
and the narrator tries to create a story
that holds them all together
but it's not inconsistent with what
you're saying actually
what you're talking about is the
machinery of dreaming i'm
talking about how the content works so i
think we could have a
joint theory here that okay that's great
but by the way i want to mention you
know my last book called the runaway
species was about what's going on with
creativity why humans and all animals
but especially humans are so creative
and it actually has to do with the fact
that everything we absorb
unlike a computer we're bending and
breaking and blending
ideas all the time so the shoe on the
nose is a perfect example of that
so yes that came out during a dream but
in some
parts of your brain that you have no
access to that's happening during the
day as well
and that's how you come up with new
ideas you think oh what if i blended
this and this and
and what happens is your brain is always
trying to solve little problems of
things
so if it said that the shoe on the nose
was the solution to something then that
would have bubbled up to your
consciousness during the day
but you're trying a billion things that
don't really lead to anything and so
your brain says sorry that you know
crossing those tracks no nothing really
out of that doesn't work yeah
yeah um going back to um the visual
cortex again we now live in a time when
we are primarily visual creatures i
would say you know we're all sitting in
front of screens
like we're doing now and most of our
work is done in front of screens more
and more of it
so what what's the effect on the human
brain when one
sense becomes so dominant as that is
there any um
feeling about that yeah i mean the
general story is that we have always
been very visual creatures
uh we rely on that um and you know
there's a sense i mean
look audible books have gained popular
there's a lot that we're doing listening
wise as well
um we don't do a lot of stuff with our
skin
uh the joke in my lab is that you know
we don't call this the waste for nothing
you know you're not really doing much
with your skin you just cover it up
and so um um but yes uh
it's exactly right what you are exposed
to
sculpts your brain so just as an example
we have many more
visual neurons in our cortex that
respond to vertical and horizontal
why because we live in a carpentered
world and um this is
this is what we expose the brain to so
we have cells that are really responsive
to this
um do we have more of those kinds of
cells than
for instance bushmen or eskimos
do do we have more of those or or do
they also get them
in theory yes in theory yes we have more
of that
um you know even somebody uh bushmen or
eskimos sees trees and sees the horizon
so they will still have plenty of that
but in theory because our whole world is
this
we have more of it it has not been
tested in terms of
bringing in bushmen and eskimos into the
scanner at some point
um your company which is called
neo-sensory
um is doing some very very interesting
work with
using that great wasted sense organ
the skin the human body perhaps you
could talk about that a little bit
yeah some years ago i got really
interested in my laboratory
and this idea of sensory substitution
which is
you know essentially your brain is
locked in silence and darkness and all
it ever gets are spikes coming in
through different data cables so you
know your eyes aren't passing light into
your brain what
what your eye does is translate photons
into
spikes electrochemical spikes that are
going back in the brain
and your ears compressing translating
air compression waves into spikes
and your skin is transmitting pain and
itching temperature and so on into
spikes
anyway all the brain ever sees are these
spikes and it just figures out what to
do with them so there's this idea that
came up actually in the late 1800s which
is
gosh could you actually feed information
to the brain via an unusual channel for
example could you feed in hearing
not through the ears but through some
other way
so in my lab we built a vest with
vibratory motors on it
and it captures sound and turns it into
patterns vibration on the skin
and deaf people can come to hear the
world this way they actually come to
hear the world
and and when i interview people about
this and i ask them okay what is it like
you know
when you hear the dog barking do you
think oh i'm feeling vibration so there
must be a dog bar can you translate or
and they say no it's just i hear the dog
barking
and if that sounds weird it's you know
remember that our own ears are just
you know capturing what's happening at
the eardrum breaking it up into
frequencies from low to high
in the cochlea shipping it off to the
brain all we're doing is we're
translating the we're
transferring the cochlea to the skin
yeah so what we've done in the last
several years is we translated this to a
uh
the vest into a wristband so it's about
the size of a fitbit it's got these um
vibratory motors so i spun this i spun
this off as a company out of my
laboratory and it's got you know these
vibratory
motors that translate the sound into
patterns on the skin and we're on wrists
all over the world so people who are
deaf
can come to hear the world around them
through their skin
so with that little device you just
showed us there how many um
separate sort of triggers are there on
that
so there the way we've built this is
with four motors but we actually take
advantage of a haptic
illusion which is if i stimulate two of
those motors you will feel a single
point in between
and as i change the amplitude of those
motors we can move that virtual point
in between so we're actually we've got
128 points that were
stimulating on the skin virtually that
way
and and humans are sensitive enough to
distinguish between those
128 points are they yes but not at first
so at first they just sort of have a
general sense
but everything about live wiring in the
brain has to do with
relevance so when your brain realizes oh
wait i'm getting information from there
that actually is meaningful to my world
then it starts devoting more real estate
to the wrist which it never really cared
that much about before
and so now it gets more and more
sensitive to differences
yeah so so uh in the um
film i've seen of you using the vest
the the very interesting thing is that
there's a lot of activity going on it's
very high density information
which of course it would have to be to
deal with language and so on
so how long does it take people to be
able to make use of that
so what's what's fascinating is it's a
linear
increase through time so on day one
after they wear it
you know for 30 minutes they're actually
better than chance on day one
and then on day two they're a little
better than that day three and so the
reason i mentioned it's a linear
increase is because
sometimes when you see performance
increases that have a big jump what that
represents is something conscious where
someone says oh i get it
but that's not what happens here instead
the brain is just slowly unlocking the
pattern and just gets better and better
at it through time
yeah and so yeah by you know by day five
people can
you know recognize particular sounds
pretty easily and by day 35
and by day 90 they're you know they're
having a conscious experience
yes the and the most interesting thing
about this to me is
well or the most unfamiliar part of it
to me
is the idea of using it to actually
create new sensors so that
that what we've been talking about so
far is using it to
replace sensors that are missing for
example so
for a deaf person to make them able to
hear a blind person to be able to see
but this possibility of actually
creating
new ways of sensing the world the aunt
sight and aunt sound
is incredibly interesting i think and
you talk
you talk in the in the book i think
about
um being able to sense a whole building
so so you're wearing a vest that tells
you about the condition of the building
that you're in very handy if you're a
janitor
but also quite nice if you're an
architect i should imagine
that's right so so we actually have
seventy seven
zero different uh projects going on now
with feeding different kinds of
information into the wristband
to um to expand our senses in something
totally new so things like you know we
started with
stock market or drones or you know just
as an example just so to make it clear
you know so as a pilot is flying a drone
around he's feeling
the pitch yaw roll and orientation on
his skin
and it's like stretching his skin up
he's one with the drone as a result of
this and that allows you to fly
much better and fly in the dark and in
the fog and things like that but
we've done this with electrical fields
with infrared vision
um you know with uh we've done this with
so many different things
if anybody's interested i'll just
mention that on on neosensory.com we
have a blog where we talk about all
these different projects that we're
doing but
yeah these are all examples of sensory
addition or expansion
where we're taking uh new data streams
and pushing them in
and the thing to the thing that's so
remarkable about it is you know we're
used to our eyes and nose and mouth and
ears and so
but these are just these are just the
things that we have inherited from a
long road of evolution
um and these capture photons in a
particular frequency
range and these capture a particular mix
of molecules and so on
but you can push any kind of information
in there and this is in the book
i you know expound my uh potato head
theory which is that it's just like when
you're a kid you've got this potato
head you plug in whatever you want you
know eyes and nose and ears whatever you
want
that's what the brain is like you can
plug in whatever sensors you want and
one of the really important things
i would say for my own thinking about
this is you know i spent a lot of time
looking across the animal kingdom
and understanding wow you have very
different weird sensors on animals you
know they can
detect electrical fields or they can
detect um infrared or ultraviolet or
uh you know whatever there's all kinds
of things animals detect
and and when i studied this carefully
looked at it it's not that there's
anything different about their brains
their brains are working on exactly the
same principles the same stuff same
neurons
um and what that told me is you can just
plug anything in and if it's relevant to
the goals of the organism it'll just
figure out how to use that data
yeah so actually there's something in
your book i'd like to read because
i i think this is a very exciting
view of the future um
you you're talking about having this way
of thinking this live wiring way of
thinking
extending it into architecture and so on
so you say
this is this is very much like david's
book some actually this is very
speculative
and interesting thinking imagine a house
that knows its own architecture
and can readjust its nervous system to
match changes
when a new room is added air ducts and
electrical wiring grow into it naturally
the brain of the house readjusts
developing a new sense of what the house
looks like
what if we engineered bricks that took
cues from each other to self-organize
into a structure
the way that the individual neurons
assemble into larger nuclei
what if buildings could shift around
dynamically optimizing their sun
exposure their shade their water access
and the amount of wind that they were
exposed to what if they were mobile
able to stand up and move to a better
spot when a fire looms or coastlines
change shape over long time scales
there's no end to the to the way that
engineering will flourish as we come to
understand live wiring
so apart from the fascination of
what we now understand about the brain
as a result of your work or the new
things that we understand
there's this possibility of a future of
intelligent mobile matter actually
and i think this is very very promising
indeed
thank you i you know um i'll tell you
the truth this is going to be my next
company that i spin off is trying to
mobile homes understand
yeah trying to build and understand
livewear because
you know i sorry i wrote the the whole
book about it and that's very exciting
but it's
not i mean we're not we're not building
things
thinking that way again everything is
about how do you make the most trim and
efficient hardware and then run a
software layer on top of that and that's
super useful for things but in fact you
know we throw out all our technology
when it becomes obsolete
um but you know i give this example at
the end of the book
um thinking about the the mars rover
spirit
which was this terrific mars rover that
nasa built we sent it up to the planet
cost
lots of money it did a great job but
then it got its right front wheel stuck
in the
martian soil and it died but when you
look at a
a wolf it gets its leg caught in a trap
what what does it do it chews its leg
off and then it figures out how to walk
on three legs is that because
wolves are pre-programmed to know how to
walk on three legs no but they figure it
out they just figure out okay how do i
operate this body and do that and then
they get back to their food and so on
this is because wolves have this sense
of
relevancy and urgency and they got you
know they've got their stomach they have
to worry about and so on
and so wouldn't it be terrific if we
could build livewear
robots that say oh i've got my right
front wheel stuck i'm just going to chew
my wheel off and then figure out how to
move around
and instead of becoming a billion dollar
piece of space junk
yes yeah so of course what we'll we'll
go to question soon but
what um is immediately interesting to me
is
is are there possibilities for us
thinking of new ways of monitoring
what is happening to the planet and and
actually feeling them
urgently everyone knows what's happening
to the planet actually
but we don't feel it yet we we need to
feel it in a
personal way we need to actually be
there somehow in
in an embodied sense and i i was
i was wondering whether you had thought
about that or worked on that at all
you know i have thought about it um one
of the issues i think is that the only
people who would wear it are the people
who already care about the planet and so
it's you know it's not clear it would
lead to more people having an
understanding of something
the other thing is as as you all so
brian and i both serve on the board of
the long now foundation
um you know on long time scales it's
difficult to get the brain to care about
things
um because you're talking changes that
are stretched over years and years
yeah so this is a this is a long-term
problem but
but i think um if we just insisted that
it was obligatory that all politicians
wore a vest
and whenever a large stretch of rain
forest got
burnt they felt they felt it on their
the smaller their back you know
it got very hot there suddenly something
like that
anyway i'll i'll look at some of the
questions here um
so from mark williams from a
neuroscientist perspective
is there really a self inside the brain
or is this
an illusion that's a big question
yeah so in livewire i propose a new
hypothesis about
the self and i think what it is
is what the brain figures out it can
control
so you know i mean there's nothing
special about you know these weird limbs
that we have
but you really your brain your three
pound mission control center realizes oh
i can move this thing around
and i can think about it and get it to
go where i want takes years to learn
this as an infant but you get pretty
good at it
so that becomes part of your notion of
itself and in fact even your mirror
image you can you know cross the room
you can move things around and it
responds as the brain wants and so you
say oh that must be
my self also but when somebody gets
damaged
to part of their body let's say they get
damaged this can happen in the brain it
can also happen from a nerve
getting severed let's say in the leg um
then they deny that the
leg is theirs they look at it and they
say that's not me it's just this weird
chalky hairy cylinder that's sitting
there
it's not me and people cook up all kinds
of weird explanations
their their brains cook up these
narratives of must be someone else's leg
or someone just sewed a leg onto me or
maybe it's the doctor's leg or something
but but
um this falls under the category of
what's called a nosagnosia which is you
know not
knowing your own body but the point is
you can't control it anymore it no
longer responds to your commands
and so then it falls from the
brotherhood of the self
yes now it's not part of you yes and so
and you notice this when you're driving
a car too i mean the car in a sense
becomes part of you and if you
you know run into something or scratch
something you kind of feel like it's
your own body um
so i think this is gonna be really
interesting as we come to
i mean and this is really near future
stuff you know as we come to control
robots for example with our thoughts and
you've got a robot on the other side of
the room doing something if something
falls on the robot and hits it you're
gonna
really flinch but anyway that's that's
my hypothesis that
the self is what you can control yeah
okay so here's another one from
anonymous attendee
i've heard that the octopus has a brain
as sophisticated as the human brain but
their bodies aren't evolved to allow
them to do anything very intelligent
how well adapted are our bodies to our
brains
could they be better than they are
you know octopuses is a fascinating
example it's an example of convergent
evolution where you find
intelligence developing in a mollusc
brain and we're
intelligence over in here in this
mammalian brain so what that
demonstrates to us is it's not
it's not impossible or that hard maybe
to to develop intelligence but occupy
have a very different world you know
they only live
typically a year um and so
because of all these strange constraints
that they have like predation because
they lost
like you know all cephalopods not
there's a whole class of cephalopods
that lost their shells
a long time ago they're vulnerable
animals they have to watch out for
predation so anyway there are a lot of
other differences uh
that account for why octopuses maybe
don't get as intelligent um as as we are
it's not
i'm not sure i agree with the first part
of the statement that their brains are
as good or better than human brains but
it is convergent evolution
of intelligence for sure it's very
interesting that they live for such a
short time is that i just discovered i
i have a lot of pheasants in my garden
pheasants have a
lifespan of only about a year as well
which could explain why they are so
stupid and habitually
fling themselves in front of passing
cars
yeah but but the short life spans of
octopuses tell us
that short lifespan doesn't have to map
on to stupid
mm-hmm they can be really intelligent
yeah
oh so this is an interesting question if
dreaming protects the visual function of
the brain
how are the other functions such as
sound and touch
protected when we sleep or maybe we
don't need to predict those
so much you don't need to protect those
because because generally they're still
getting stimulated so you hear sounds
when you sleep
you know whether it's the campfire or
animals or wind or rustling around or
whatever
you're still feeling those and of course
your whole body you know you're as
you're rolling over and stuff you're
feeling stuff all over your skin all the
time and presumably you know if there's
smells around and so on
they're getting a lot less activity than
normal but nonetheless
uh they're getting a lot more than the
visual system which is completely shut
off
yes at that point yeah yes and by the
way i'll just mention a side note
because because
people ask this all the time they say
wait a minute there's a hole in your
theory what about blind people but
but what happens with blind people you
know this this dreaming circuitry is
ancient all animals sleep a dream sorry
all animals dream
so it's a very ancient circuitry but
what happens if you go blind
you're still having dreams you're still
pumping activity into the visual system
why because it's you know very deeply
in-built circuitry that does that
but what's interesting is for a blind
person this whole area is taken over by
hearing and touch and so their dreams
are that they say oh yeah i was walking
around the room
and feeling the furniture and but
everything was rearranged and bizarre
and then i felt and
there was a bear in the corner and i
felt him and i ran away and
but that's what their dreams are it's
the same exact activity getting pumped
in it's just that it's no longer visual
cortex it's
other stuff yep um
what are the implications of the
ever-changing brain
for machine learning will it help
improve driverless cars and other smart
technology
yeah great question and this is a big
part of why my next company is going to
be about
really building this stuff machine
learning is so impressive and so much of
what's happening in silicon valley is
all about
machine learning but there are various
parts of it that are just
you know missing for example there's no
sense of relevance in machine learning
uh it doesn't care about um survival or
anything like that
it's just you know if you feed it
millions of pictures dogs and cats and
whatever it'll do that but machine
learning
even though it's so impressive
it's not widely understood about the
massive limitations of it it's only
really good at
very well-defined problems um
where you can define very clear rules on
it like like games um you know
chess or go these seem like complicated
games they have very simple rule sets
machine learning is great at that stuff
but it's not good at anything a
three-year-old human can do
you know a three-year-old human can walk
into a room and look around and navigate
it
and uh and manipulate adults and you
know feed herself and do you know do 100
things that that machine learning just
can't do
and it's not that we won't get there but
i think we're going to have to rethink
many fundamental assumptions about how
we um
you know how we plug in my slogan lately
is
you know if you want to build a robot
start with the stomach by which i simply
mean it needs to have motivation it
needs to have a reason to do what it's
doing
um you know if you had a robot roll into
the room just now it actually wouldn't
be able to do anything because there's
no sense of
stacking priorities and knowing what is
the next thing that it wants to do
yeah yeah somebody just asked how many
pheasants are in my garden
it's usually about eight or nine um
so somebody else i think we may have
answered this question but
it might have some other things to say
to uh we frequently hear that our brains
become less elastic as we get older
is this true and if so is there anything
we can do about it
you know the only thing i'll say to add
on to what we already talked about is
just
a lot of a lot of times we feel this
fantasy that we'd like to have more
plastic brains we
you know as as we're getting older we'd
love to so for example i'm i've been
trying to teach myself chinese
and and it's much harder now than it
would have been when i was five years
old
um but the fact is let's say
neuroscientists came up with some
magical potion and said here
take this potion and this will reinstate
plasticity all over your brain and you
can become like a child again
if you took it you would lose you you
would lose
everything that makes up who you are
because who you are is the sum total of
all the memories and experiences that
you've gathered during a lifetime you're
essentially the way i described in the
book is you're essentially a vessel
of space and time and you've gone
through the world and vacuumed up a
particular
trajectory of experiences you were born
in a particular town in a particular
year
and that's who you are so if you were
offered this pill where you could learn
chinese in a week
it wouldn't be worth it i think you'd
lose you and you'd become
an infant again speaking of memory
this morning i was sitting at breakfast
and reading something and
the phrase two faces came up and i
suddenly remembered a song
called two faces have i and i thought
that was by lou christie wasn't it
now i haven't thought of that song or of
lou christie
for at least 55 years
can you give me any idea of what was
happening to that memory in that
intervening 55 years
where is it what is it so great question
okay so right you've got this
you know 86 billion neurons and half a
trillion
connections synapses between them and
what happens is this is the remarkable
thing about
being able to store memory which we're a
particularly good species at
um so this thing came in it was somehow
relevant to you as a child and it got
stored
uh one of the hypotheses that i explore
in the book is
that is that there's actually um
things get more cemented in with time by
the way this is this is the oldest rule
in neurology is that
um older memories are more stable than
newer memories just as a quick side note
you know um if any of you have seen
somebody get dementia for example in
their older age
they can't remember what they did last
week or last month or last year but they
remember their childhood just fine
and that's because the older memories
are cemented in at a deeper
level but anyway this is the remarkable
thing is that we go through life and
things that are relevant
to us get get stuck in there
and that's what makes us who we are by
the way there was just a recent study
where
people did brain scanning on adults who
use pokemon
toys as kids and and they still have
lots of brain activation
because they remember the stuff that
they did 20 years ago there's a very
interesting piece in
in the book about synaesthesia where it
turns out that a lot of synesthetes who
identify numbers as the same colors and
they happen to be the colors of the
fisher-price alphabet from the 1980s
i believe so yeah so yeah
sort of imprinted on a lot of people
exactly just as a quick side note so you
know i
built this this online synesthesia
battery to test people
and what we found is that you know all
synesthetes
who experience color when they see
letters of the alphabet they all have
random different things and it's
presumably because
you can think about it as random wiring
between these
areas that code for letters and these
colors you think about it that way but
i also started wondering if maybe this
had to do with what you happen to be
exposed to
um as a kid you know your your
kindergarten teacher had a quilt with
different color a and b and c or you
picked up crayons of different colors
whatever
but yes what we found what my colleagues
at sanford and i discovered is that
when we looked at the battery there were
in some years up to 15
of people had this same pattern a is red
and b is blue and c is yellow and so
yeah and it was the fisher-price
alphabet set that they were imprinting
on as children
yeah that's very interesting uh this is
a question that says
this is one for david and brian machine
learning is already composing music
some of it sounds okay could the
machines put brian out of work
well i can tell you no because i'm
designing the machines
so i'm still gonna have a job
[Laughter]
but um it's it's actually these are very
interesting questions about
whether whether machines can be creative
and of course
the machines aren't being creative
what's what's being creative is us who
are designing them and making choices
about them and
defining the parameters of the kinds of
uh choices they will make so
at the moment there aren't any you might
be reassured or disappointed to know
there aren't any
actually um creative machines
there are machines that can do lots and
lots of interesting things with inputs
that we give them
things that we wouldn't do ourselves and
and then we can make judgments about
them but it's still it's still
us making the judgments so so
i'll just alley-oop off that because i
um
i think you you hit it there at the end
which is that so all brains are doing
i mentioned earlier my last book runaway
species brains are taking in data
and crunching it mixing it doing new
things and saying hey what about this
what about this what about this and most
of it
is garbage but every once in a while you
think oh that would make a good riff
that that makes sense so what machines
are really good at doing machine
learning
is that bending breaking blending and
putting things together
in amazing ways and i think that is
creativity that's the same as what human
brains are doing
but there's the second part creativity
that brains do which is the filtering
yeah so it's smashing new things
together and then filtering almost all
of them out and
that second part is the part that
machines can't do yeah currently yes
because they don't know what it is to be
a human and what would appeal to us
so just as an example you know google
deep dream for example
makes these incredible combinations of
different styles and items and you get
these paintings out of it that are
remarkable but the ones you see online
that are remarkable are the ones that
were hand selected
by humans who thought wow that's pretty
cool most of them are garbage
yeah yeah yes um okay so
james cole asks do we have free will
this is
a subject that i know you've dealt with
in one of at least one of your other
books
yes quite quite like yeah it's a very
very
interesting question this yeah exactly
you know i i'm a scientific advisor on
the show west world and you know this is
essentially what we spent eight hours in
a in the writers room talking about is
this question
and and the answer to your question is
we don't actually know
in neuroscience we don't we don't think
so i would say most neuroscientists the
huge majority think we probably don't
and the reason is
because this is a vastly complicated
system but in the end it's just a system
it's a machine it's every neuron is
responding to other neurons and so on
it's not clear where you get this diffic
puff of breath coming in that would
be something other than a machine that's
running
so that's why most neuroscientists land
on the side that we probably don't have
free will
but it certainly feels like we have free
will and one possibility is that
you know our science is still quite
young and in
500 years we might our neuroscience
textbooks are going to look very
different than they look right now
and maybe we'll understand something
that we didn't uh quite get and but you
know just as a quick side note about
westworld is
so you know we debated this i presented
all sides of the argument and they've
done a terrific job
of keeping it right down that middle of
not
quite knowing for those of you who've
seen the show you know the hosts the
robots
um every time they feel like they have
free will
you know one of the robots gives this
speech on you know how he's now
free and as he's giving the speech the
speech writer
echoes him at the same time and says the
words with him indicating that it's
actually not
a free speech that he's giving yeah
right
um here's a here's a very nice question
for a speculative mind
what sense that doesn't exist yet would
david and brian
most like to bring into existence
can can i answer that one to start um
please
i i would love to have
a very refined social sense which
told me what a lot of other people were
thinking what they were really thinking
i would like to have not been so
shocked at the brexit vote or
the trump vote i i would like to well in
fact i predicted both of those
but i had no idea that my prediction was
going to come true
it was shocking to me that so many
people made a decision that was
utterly incomprehensible to me so i wish
i could comprehend what other people's
minds were seeing
that's perhaps the sense i would like
theory of mind but a kind of amplified
version of it you know
so let me let me mention for my answer
three different ways that we're working
on that so one of them is
you may remember from this ted talk i
gave one of the things we've done is
where we can scrape twitter for any
particular hashtag
and you can uh pass that through an
automated sentiment analysis so we know
you know generally what people are
saying about it and so you can
feel thousands of tweets a second you
can feel a summary of what's going on
in real time um so that's one way to get
some data from lots of people at once
but then there's something else we've
done which is we've built um
so take a smart there are lots of smart
watches that will measure things like
your
heart rate and your heart rate
variability and your galvanic skin
response and so on
and so we've made it so that you can
feel
that on on the wristband so these states
of the body that are normally invisible
to you
you can feel that but the cool part is
you can feel someone else's physiology
so you put this
wristband on someone else and you feel
when they are getting stressed
when things are happening and we've just
now made it where one person can wear
the watch and multiple people can
feel what's going on with their
physiology
now i have no idea if this will be
useful for marriages or you know
anti-useful
but but it's just a cool thing to try uh
that we're testing out and i'll just
mention that there's a
some some young college students just
came up with a um
a version of input for the buzz that
they've spun off as their own
startup company now which is for
children with autism who have a
difficult time
registering the emotions of the person
they're talking to they don't know if
the person is happy or sad or angry
um so the the buzz the neocountry buzz
does machine learning
figures out from tone of voice about the
emotion going on and then tells the user
you know oh this person is angry this
person is happy and so on
so that the child with autism can just
get what's going on just be told what's
going on that way
and have you have you actually done
these experiments
those are those are ongoing right now
those are underway right now oh really
yeah that'll be very interesting um
okay we've got a couple more questions i
guess how long
would someone who wasn't born blind but
lost sight in childhood
and has a memory of the world be likely
to hold the sight memory in their brain
yeah it's a great question um what we
know generally is that
if you're born blind your visual system
gets taken over entirely so you of
course never even have a notion of sight
the older you are when you go blind the
less and less takeover there is because
for example if you've been using your
eyes till you're 25 years old and then
you go blind
because of something wrong with your
eyes your visual system is pretty well
cemented in place and so even though
there's some
some little bit of takeover it's not
it's not a lot and in fact
sorry let me just jump back to one thing
this thing about dreaming
infants spend half their sleep time in
rem sleep but as you get older and older
you have less and less dream sleep
because it's just less and less
important
because your visual system is cemented
itself into place so so the answer is
there's a very smooth continuum about
depending on what age you go blind
but yes you're right people who go blind
later have a
sense a memory of what it was like to
see and therefore when they
you know when they touch things in the
world they're still
mapping it on to what it must look like
yes
yes um
will you agree that one act that robots
can never do
is meditation for that matter should not
humanity at this crossroads of all
things ai go deeper in and build the
spiritual circuit
i don't know quite which which circuit
that is that you might know
i i love questions that that begin will
you agree
because you know i don't know i mean i
i'm not necessarily
um just imagine where our science will
be
1 720 years from now i mean
the idea that we couldn't have a robot
that meditates
sure we could should we get everyone
that meditates because we are built of
physical pieces and parts and all mother
nature had to work with was you know
cells and putting them together in these
very sophisticated ways but when we
understand this
in a great time from now there's no
reason we can't build robots that have
exactly the same kind of
concerns and uh foibles and aspirations
that we have including
wanting to go off to a retreat at esslin
and meditate for a week
yes i mean is is the acceleration of
or the birth of intelligence just to do
with complexity you know if we
if if machines keep getting more and
more and more complex
or is there actually a state change
where suddenly
something new appears you know i don't
think
that's an interesting question about the
state change i think it's just a matter
of getting the principles right so
having more and more complex computers
isn't going to do it i mean already
the computational capacity we have on
the planet
well outstrips anything a human brain
can do but it's not intelligent
in the way that a human brain is because
we don't have the principles right
this is the last thing i'll say han i
see you've come back on which means we
have to wrap up soon but i'll just say
we've got this the main textbook that we
use in the field is called principles of
neural science it's the the main
neuroscience textbook is about 800
something pages
and it's totally misnamed because if it
were really principles it would be the
size of a pamphlet
and we'll get there someday but but we
don't right now it's just a core dump of
everything we know um yes anyway sorry
i'll wrap up because i see you
am i am i allowed one other question
because there's a very interesting one
here how does the brain generate
something as breathtakingly strong
as intense romantic love and how can we
train the brain to get over heartbreak
so okay great so let me answer those in
backwards order i have a
section in the book about heartbreak and
how heartbreak
i suggest is just like drug withdrawal
in the following sense
when you're taking a drug your brain
gets used to it it expects the presence
of that drug it actually
changes in this plastic way around the
expectation that the drug will be there
suddenly you stop taking it
and your brain has to struggle with the
fact that it thought it should be there
i suggest this is exactly the same with
heartbreak you love somebody
a parent a lover or whatever it is that
person disappears
and your brain expects the presence of
that person and struggles with the
absence of that
because even though we don't normally
think about this your brain
so much of your brain circuitry is about
other people it's simulating it's
running other people
what they'll say how they'll react how
they're feeling and suddenly that person
is gone and you're not getting the the
key in the lock anymore there
and so there i think is no way to train
the brain to get over heartbreak it's
the same as withdrawing from a drug you
just have to wait
for that to happen yeah and then as far
as
oh sorry were you gonna say something
right no no okay
i was just gonna say as far as how how
the brain generates romantic love
i mean the weird part and it's so hard
because we've all been there
so it's so hard for us to recognize that
we are just evolutionarily
programmed to be there it's very useful
to have this it's what causes
not just mating but bonding which is
really useful for child rearing
and um to my so i'm writing this in my
next book actually which is about
reality about the reality we perceive
and i think one way to see this
excuse me for saying something that
sounds gross uh
i apologize but it's an important
biological point which is that you know
when you think about the
let's say sexuality and this person that
you love
you have all kinds of great things
swirling around your head but if you
think about
the genitalia of another species
it's disgusting it's repulsive right but
it's only because you're programmed
there i i only mentioned this gross
point to illustrate that you are
programmed to find that person's
genitalia the most amazing thing in the
world and not so much for
a sp for a different species anyway
everything about romantic love is this
way where you
you know your internal model of the
person you think they're really
wonderful
and um yeah but we are we are programmed
for this
so you've never had a relationship with
a squid then
exactly sorry to end on such a weird
note but i just think it's an important
biological point
okay well thank you so much david it was
a pleasure talking to you
see you soon